ala Bella is with us in Silver Springs
Maryland hey Ella Belle how are you hi
Dave oh my goodness I can't believe I'm
talking to you so good afternoon how are
you
I'm honored how can I help alright so my
ex-husband and I own a house together
here after a divorce yet under the house
I began making mortgage payments because
I was afraid my credit will get damaged
if I didn't them so I took him to court
and then law story short the court order
for him to repay me back the money to
have paid plus he was ordered to
continue to pay the mortgage as of their
order was effective February and this
month as of the day he has not paid I
asked him and he's hiding money I have a
job whatever excuses
we are already 27 days late and I would
like to know other than taking him back
to court for failure to follow the court
order what can I do to alert the bank in
the credit bureau that I have a court
order ordered him to pay or even hear
nothing you have you have a mortgage
with your name on it that is not being
paid on time period and it's going to
show as negative on your credit report
so what you need to do is you need to
have your login put a motion before the
judge to force the sale of the house
against that an estate is going to say I
have a trustee right now that is working
to place the house on the market
don't worry working on and they just you
know few things and I getting things
ready
nobody another week we should have it in
the market by Sunday you don't pay the
bill until until if you have the money
if you can pay it pay it until it's sold
yeah I have taken money out of my
retirement account and I know you I know
I had to I had to it was either that I
felt it you know to me like we know what
to do imagine what is your income and my
income is about 93 thousand dollars a
year how much is the house prime the
house payment is one thought
and $693 and i have another house as
well how much was your other house my
house is about I'm paying 1700 a flat
rate because I'm adding more you know
about dollars a month 1,700
I do have roommates that pay me can I
help with the rent are you on a really
tight budget I mean with a tight budget
can you not make both temporarily I
don't want make it long but just to keep
to keep from hitting your retirement
account yes I have you know kind of
reduced my hands are taming am i
traveling at less of course I'm trying
to I would doing everything down to
nothing and keep it current and then of
course have the is the house got equity
in it it does okay how the judge just
give you a ruling that you get your
money back out of equity before there's
any split I do have that and thankfully
is in place but by the time I see any of
that money I will have to continue so
let me ask it is going for I'm just
saying I would rather you get on a beans
and rice budget than cash out your
retirement and can barely live and do
you get this house sold but let's get
this house on the market get it sold
ASAP what is it worth and that issue
probably 340 but since my trustee says
that and I really have about sixty
thousand dollars in equity good let's go
to Seoul ASAP and and then you know it's
just that was just my only worried and
my question to you as far as beyond you
know at the credit bureau nothing you
can do when a hal attainment that has
your name on it is not paid on time
they're going to report you as being
late because you are late cuz i
understand why it's happened and you can
put an explanation on your credit bureau
report if you want that the ex-husband
was supposed to pay it and didn't but
you know what nobody cares
they don't care here but does the bottom
line is your credit score is going to go
down as a result of bozo here yes I work
for the government I can't have had
happening I'm okay for that that's so I
mean the answer to this is put the house
on the market cheap and get it sold
quick like in two days yeah you might
take five to six months according to the
species an idiot the market is not that
slow
in Maryland it doesn't take six months
to sell a house in our current world in
Maryland okay that makes me feel better
because she said you know we have to get
approved by the by big court well I mean
there's a panic here you got you jump in
the court already and tell the trustee
we're not sitting around waiting I'm
paying 1700 freakin dollars a month
we're not going to wait six months for
some judge to get off his robe oh no
we're going to be bothering everybody
and so you know you the trustee wants to
make a career out of this crap you need
to have a new trustee oh gosh
okay I mean we need to get everybody to
get their tail on fire here for your
sake you're the one getting screwed by
this whole thing
no the trustees not getting screwed the
judge isn't getting screwed the law your
in getting screwed your ex-husband is a
bozo
he doesn't care you're the only ones got
anything in this game right so if I'm
you I'm going to be pleasant but I'm
gonna be jacking everybody in this story
up regularly let's get this house on the
market yesterday and get online and
check Dave Ramsey calm and check to see
if you if we've got a realtor that we
endorse in your area in our ELP program
I endorse local provider program that'll
be a high octane realtor and tell them
that you need to price this thing in
such a way that it's going to sell in a
matter of days not months and then mr.
trustee or miss trustee nice get off
their butt and get this approved by the
judge in 24 freakin hours not in 24
months because they want to keep
collecting a trustee fee BS no get this
thing done get it done you gotta get out
of your life kiddo
it's taking you down hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]